Nicole you guys just did what no team
has done this year in the NBA and that's
beat the Boston Celtics here in this
building what did it take to get that
job done I mean they they scor 100
points you know they they uh they I
think they're really good offensive
offensive team and we we took care of
the defense today and that's why we won
the game I think the final two defensive
possessions you defend with about 14
seconds left they call timeout you have
to defend again walk me through your
mentality there I mean we had a foul to
give so we knew even if they that we can
we can we can foul so that's going to
take couple seconds off but kcb did a
really good job that's why he's probably
first team first first team uh first
team NBA defense so um it was a tough
interesting game and um I'm glad that we
won you and Jamal combined for 69 of the
total 102 points what led to that type
of production between the two of you I
mean Jamal Jamal Jamal played really
good the last quarter he scor 12 I think
or 14 something in in the last quarter
he he he he he was a really good energy
guy for us and he he didn't want to lose
today he got he got a dog inside of him
and he he he he was amazing tonight big
night for you too congrats on the thank
you